people in Sudan have endured a second
day of fierce fighting between the Army
and the country's biggest paramilitary
Force earlier on Sunday they had a brief
respite from the violence during a
three-hour humanitarian pause well this
is the scene right now in Khartoum
fighting between the Army and the rapid
support forces began on Saturday the
World Health Organization says at least
83 people have been killed and hundreds
injured since then the violence was
sparked by disagreement over the
paramilitary group's integration into
the military as part of the transition
to civilian rule well this is the state
of play in Sudan with fighting now
spread across the country for the worst
of the violence has been centered in the
capital Khartoum and the neighboring
city of Underman both sides have been
vying for control of the estate
broadcaster the presidential Palace the
airport and various military bases our
correspondent Heber Morgan has more now
from Khartoum
in the capital there's still conflicting
reports with regards to who controls
what we do know that there are rsf
troops around the presidential Palace
it's not clear if they have full control
uh of that and that even that is
symbolic their the presidential Palace
is where the offices uh of the president
or the head of the ruling council is
it's not where his residence is then
there's the issue of the general command
of the Army headquarters in the early
hours of Sunday morning there was heavy
bombardments and heavy fighting around
the vicinity of the general command and
even now more than 12 hours later we can
still hear the sound of fighter jets
flying over the Skies of hartum we can
still hear the sound of anti-aircraft
missiles being fired and it's not clear
from which direction they're coming at
but it's clear that the Sudanese Army is
continuing to launch airstrikes against
the rsf and the rsf is continuing to try
to counter those attacks this is the
situation around the capital many people
are in panic on the second day of the
fighting between the rsf and the Armed
Forces
smoke rises above hortum as fighting
between Sudan's Army and its biggest
paramilitary group entered its second
day
from above fighter jets Circle the
capital while the military warns people
to stay indoor the two sides are
fighting for control the military and
the rapid support forces both claim to
be in control of important locations
around the country
but in some parts the Army says it's
gained ground taking bases run by the
paramilitary forces
on Sunday afternoon both sides agreed to
assist fire for three hours on
humanitarian grounds starting at 4 pm
local time that was violated an hour
later the pause in fighting targeted
those who have been trapped in places
like hospitals and schools since
Saturday many were cut off from food and
drinking water as fighting between the
Army and the rapid support forces killed
dozens and injured hundreds more
fighting also took place in residential
areas area of heavy fighting then it's
blocked off by soldiers and there's
gunshots and snipers and from here you
can't see any any dead bodies but I have
um my friends who are in that zone and
they can't leave their house the
fighting has spread to the eastern city
of Port Sudan on durman and Bahrain
disrupting energy and Water Supplies
hospitals are in lockdown
it's not safe at home to go outside
even even the doctors cannot read the
hospitals I cannot reach the hospital
even even the ambulance even the
ambulance cannot move in the streets the
violence began on Saturday after weeks
of tension between Army Chiefs
and his Deputy Muhammad hamdan commander
of the rapid support forces each leader
is accusing the other of starting the
fight and refusing to negotiate
the United Nations African Union the
United States and Regional leaders are
calling for an end to the hostilities
there are concerns it could become a
full-scale war and possibly spill over
into neighboring countries the main
priority that that really I would say is
shared by all of the original countries
is to prevent this from moving into a
full-blown Civil War we are close to
that but we're not we're not really at
that point yet because because this
country's share border with Sudan they
know that the devastation of a civil war
will lead to so many issues around
illegal migration and refugees flowing
out of Sudan into countries that are
already verified their countries you
know South Africa Republic Ethiopia has
its issues you know Egypt as well
despite the growing International
pressure to stop the fighting and
attempt at a ceasefire it's unclear if
these two leaders are willing to put
aside their differences and commit to
talks Heber Morgan Al Jazeera Khartoum
for the video blogger who's traveling in
Sudan has shared his experience of
what's happening in cartoon
when I opened the window I could see the
black smoke around the air a lot of
people they are going by walking they
are going with their bags many of the
people they are loading the stuff from
Supermarket they are going in their car
and many of them they were hitchhiking
in another vehicles to escape the city
well there's also been fighting in the
city of merui which lies Northwest of
Khartoum with the battle for control of
the airport and an air base Al jazeera's
Osama side Ahmed is there
we've been hearing gunfire of both light
and heavy weapons which was likely to
Signal renewed fighting here within the
vicinity of marawi airport soon it all
came to a halt and what remains is the
plumes of smoke from the vital
installations within the facility close
to its control tower as you can see this
is the aftermath of the fighting that
began a short while ago the rapid
support forces had said they had seized
control of the marawa airport claims
denied by senior sources we contacted in
the Sudanese Army here in the northern
Province they confirmed the airport is
under the Army's control as the armed
forces deal with what they're calling
small pockets of rebels an apparent
reference to the rapid support forces
original block of Nations is planning to
send the presidents of Kenya South Sudan
and the Djibouti to mediate in Sudan the
intergovernmental Authority on
development or egad says the leaders
will be heading there as soon as
possible the African Union has also
called for an end to hostilities its
chairman will also be going to Khartoum
to discuss an immediate ceasefire and
the Arab League has held an emergency
meeting to discuss the situation
Hassan Zaki is the assistant Secretary
General of the Arab League he says the
alliance is reaching out to both parties
it is difficult in these times for the
two
concerned parties the commanders General
burhan on one side on the other side
it's difficult to place the calls and
stake them but we are doing our best in
logistical terms it's a bit a bit
difficult but yes we are we are trying
to get these calls done before the end
of today we understand their concern
that they do not want
um foreign involvement in their own
Affairs
because they are wary that such
involvement may take shapes that will
not be beneficial to their own security
and stability
we heard the Ambassador speak not only
in the public part of the session but
also
in in the part that was not covered by
the media and yet he said things similar
to that but as when it comes to the Arab
League they know exactly what we are
what we stand for they do not have
anything to worry about we are there as
brothers to try to help them
get over this very very bumpy segment of
the road and to end this current
military confrontation
the country's former prime minister
Abdullah handok says he's opposed to
foreign involvement hamdock was deposed
in a military coup in 2021 he also wants
a humanitarian Corridor to give
civilians access to food and medicine I
do
foreign
I call for denying any foreign
intervention in Sudanese Affairs we ask
the International Community to have a
positive role to support the return of
political dialogue and I invite once
again the military and the rapid support
forces to hold negotiations now to solve
the disagreements that have led to this
situation